Batman has had a bunch of different
outfits through his ears on screen let's
go back for a look at all of his bat
fashion decisions in his first
appearance in the original 1943 serial
Batman Dawn's an armored lyst grey
outfit with black suede boots and a
matching KCAL combo but the thing that
really sets off his outfit is his
awesome bedazzled belt compared to the
Snyder version I would say it's less
than tactical as it would be hard to
sneak up on villains with that gorgeous
belt most belgerman would better get out
of here we don't have complete to find
it needs outfit six years later Batman
comes back his belt is shrunk but his
bat symbol has gotten larger still no
armor yet but the intimidation from that
big chest mounted bat should scare some
baddies away huh wasn't that silly yes
in 1966 Batman comes back the bat symbol
is now on a yellow background his
utility belt offers slightly more
utility and his purple cape cowl combo
now has the facial expression it was
missing from previous iterations just
drawn right on there right on his mask
like eyeliner Batman I say no more
rubbing it could be compromising of
course in 1989 Batman finally gets
armored squeaky black rubber armor ABS
included above a bright yellow belt the
pronounced brow on the mask protects
Batman's face and keeps his true
emotions hidden this bat suit looks a
thousand percent more badass than its
predecessors even though you can't move
your neck while wearing it nice outfit
batman returns but his suit has a new
logo the previous organic curves now are
more industrial looking but the new
angular armor seems to be weak against
cats Batman Forever has to bat suits the
first has a very on-brand yellow bat
symbol and what every bat suit is lacked
up until this point bat nipples the
second suit is a silvery black and
features sonar capabilities the bat
symbol that spreads across the chest is
set right into the black there are two
batsuits featured in Batman and Robin as
well suit one is pretty basic Batman it
loses the yellow bat symbol but brings
back those bat nipples the second suit
is set up for ice combat the best part
about this bat suit is for the first
time the bat crew all matches it's also
really well known for its armored
codpiece I hope you got about 10 million
more those little toys batman begins
with the first bat suit that has a
backstory nomex of iowa suit advanced
infantry spray painted black with the
addition of League of Shadows bracers
the utility belt is back to a shade of
yellow although it's made of metal
instead of vinyl whatever it was and for
62 years of engineering the cowl becomes
a helmet so fat man can look around just
kidding they haven't invented that
technology yet we will the dark knight
and dark knight rises are where the
Batsuit starts going function over form
the suit gets more segmented and a lot
more armor like a tank engineer went
into men's ninja fashion design perhaps
you should read the instructions first
the Batman vs Superman bat suit is skin
tight but isn't back to the black rubber
armor of the 80s and 90s the weave cloth
looks like it could stop a bullet and
the large bat symbol on the chest will
be easily recalled by anyone Batman has
punched also it pairs well with a trench
coat and goggles the armored overcoat
the suit gets is definitely great for a
night on the town get it if that night
includes picking fights with
super-powered aliens or big angry
mutants the armor lacks a bat symbol but
the illuminated eyes still cast a
frightening vistage
I figured the Cape the Batsuit has
evolved over seven decades but I would
be proud of wearing any of them to
comic-con or on a date for more on that
fashion or anything else about your
favorite movies TV shows or comics check
out gamespot universe